[Musique]
sa fille
on écoute quand nathan il va siffler
vous allez vous mettre sur le devant
des familles avec des bébés vêtements de
l'été et puis moi / minute il ya des
prix
[Musique]
tu viens me coupant louis et mon copain
thomas hamon sport et jésus tout indique
que la les bras ils vont être bras
dessus bras dessous voilà et là le but
ça va être de retourner la copine de la
mettre sur le dos et d'attraper foulard
hop
voilà c'est bien la lutte ça peu comment
on peut commencer à partir de 3 ans et
demi quatre ans pour commencer cd je
lutte c'est vraiment apprendre à
respecter le copain à écouter c'est
vraiment l' équilibre de savoir tenir de
mettre sur le dos copains c'est pour
être vraiment et la seaco et seront plus
grands vraiment d'être sous parce qu'ils
font vraiment de la souplesse à la luce
pla vous allez prendre de l'élan et on
va courir
gt1 et dans le monde
que lorsqu'il club souvent je m'
électrocutaient
en effet vous sortez d'un profond kahn à
ses
capés
[Musique]
et
là
on va au sommet avec les copines la
brouette les galipettes cdc des
crocodiles aller au regard des allées de
crocodile et l'autre est plus celle
acquise par quatre paco et faute honte
pour faire connaître les acquis et de
boue
a joué à enlever les fours à des offres
et on a joué aussi à enlever le ballon
je fais du sport je cours et je me
détend bien
sur le jeu qu'on a fait de lui mettre
sur le dos là quand on prenait le ballon
ici l'appui qu'on mettait le copain sur
le dos je vous rappelle qu'à la lutte
contre le copain elle est sur le dos
vous avez perdu
ok gardez vous venez sur le dos on
revient sur levante ouais
adjedj
jeudi